A major foreword from staffer is now predicting
that Donald Trump will ultimately resigned
the presidency of the United States.
And I'm going to have her comments for you
in a moment, but listen, we've talked about
this before.
Uh, I, every time I say this, I get a few
angry emails.
I don't think Trump is going to be removed
by impeachment.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
Uh, I don't think Donald Trump is going to
resign, but I do believe that if Donald Trump
started to seriously believe that he was at
risk of being removed and possibly facing
criminal prosecution, I think that is the
one scenario under which he might resign.
The former vice president of the Trump organization,
Barbara arrests is saying exactly this, that
Trump is acting just the way he used to act
at the Trump organization.
The paranoia, the anger flying off the handle,
and that he might resign specifically to save
face.
She said this to CNN, check it out.
And when Kellyanne Conway's husband says he's
unfit for office, do you agree with that assessment?
I do, yes.
But I thought that when he was running, and
not, not for necessarily the mental reasons
that they talk about, but because he didn't
have the experience, you know, lots of different
things.
So how do you see this ending now?
Does it end to the ballot box in a year?
Does he make it to a second term?
Does he resign as a result of impeachment?
What do you think?
You know, it's funny, I, people ask me that
and I'm thinking, you know, it's hard to say
my opinion on national TV shows.
I could very well be wrong, but let me, let
me tell you what I thought.
I mean, I think that he does a lot of things
to save face.
And I could give you examples.
We don't have time, but I mean, there are
some things that, you know, he can't control
and he's now at the point where he can't control
this.
He can't do anything about this.
Um, it would be very, very, very bad for him
to be impeached, impeached.
I don't know that he'd be found guilty, but
I don't think he wants to be impeached.
I think he, I think that's what this panic
is about and my gut tells me he'll leave office,
he'll resign or make some kind of a deal even
depending on what comes out.
The deal thing is a bigger and bigger part
of this.
Once again, I don't believe that this is heading
to an impeachment conviction.
Some in my audience disagree with me, but
as soon as that becomes a reality, if it ever
does, we immediately start getting into does
Trump pull Pence down with him?
Does Trump set Mike Pence up to pardon him?
If he preemptively resigns, does he pull pens
down but make a deal for Pences replacement
with someone that will pardon him?
And then there's also a completely opposite
assessment of all of this, which some people
are making, which is even though Trump doesn't
like the idea of articles of impeachment,
there is a position to be staked out, which
I think is a reasonable one that a failed
impeachment attempt or even an inquiry that
doesn't go well could re-energize Donald Trump's
base.
It could get some Republicans who are sort
of lukewarm on Trump to just bite the bullet
and vote for the guy.
That is not a crazy prediction about how this
could go.
Now, as far as how you know, the Barbara Rez
thing goes, of course right away, Trumpists
are attacking her.
She's clearly not clued in to what Trump would
do.
She just wants to malign Trump.
She doesn't really know Trump.
I even saw some comments online saying Trump
would never sleep with this woman.
Is that like even an issue here?
I didn't think that that was on the table.
Anyway, this is not a particularly difficult
to believe assessment.
I believe that Donald Trump will do anything
he can to not only avoid impeachment but to
avoid resignation.
But if it really came down to it, if the rubber
really started meeting the road, Trump might
resign to avoid an impeachment conviction.
Nixon did it.
It's not a shocking thing to think might happen
if it went that way, but it's nice to see
that the Trumpists immediately identify personal
attacks against a woman as the way to defend
Donald Trump against any critical statement
against their dear leader.
It completely predictable in every way.
Barbara rests.
Let me know what you think.
I basically agree with her.
I think where I disagree with Barbara RS is
I don't believe this scenario will come to
pass.
I do agree that to save face a coroner, Trump
who believes he will be removed by impeachment
would resign.
I just don't believe it's going to get to
that point.
Let me know what you think.
Makes sure you are following the show on Twitch
at twitch.tv/david Pakman live livestreams
will be resuming soon.
Quick break back after this with much more